vamos a realizar un problema de
crecimiento exponencial y si se fijan
ustedes lo que vamos a hacer ahorita con
bacterias no es diferente a lo que
hicimos anteriormente con interés
compuesto cuando aprendimos sobre
intereses y el número y bueno no se
preocupen les voy a mostrar las
analogías conforme vayamos resolviendo
este problema ese es un problema de
crecimiento compuesto o de crecimiento
exponencial y dice un cultivo de
bacterias contiene inicialmente 100
células y crece a una razón proporcional
a su tamaño después de una hora el
número de bacterias se ha incrementado a
420 y el primer inciso es encontrar una
expresión para el número de bacterias
después de 'the horas y siempre que
estemos trabajando con el crecimiento
exponencial o decaimiento exponencial o
un crecimiento continuo compuesto o
decaimiento continuo compuesto la
cantidad de lo que tenemos está en
función del tiempo en este caso diremos
que el crecimiento bacterial está en
función del tiempo
voy a escribirlo aquí vd las bacterias
están en función del tiempo
y va a ser igual
la cantidad inicial de bacterias que nos
hayan indicado para el interés compuesto
es la cantidad con la que iniciamos x
^ la que aporte
de acá es nuestro grado de composición
en general si ustedes tienen esta y 0
tiene sentido de que si ésta te es igual
a cero todo esto va a ser igual a 1 así
que ve de 0 sería igual a la cantidad
inicial así que saben en donde inician y
en otro punto nada más hay que
despejarla acá y ya tenemos esta
expresión la expresión que necesitamos
para resolver este primer inciso
encontrar una expresión para el número
de bacterias después de horas así que mi
primera pregunta es que es esta y decir
cuál es el número inicial de bacterias
bueno eso no nos dan nos dicen que en el
inicio contiene 100 células en el
momento inicial cuando te es igual a
cero vamos a tener ve de cero igual a
y de cero es igual a 100 si sustituimos
aquí te iguala 0 este exponente va a ser
cero por lo que este valor completo va a
ser 1 así que nos queda 100 para que
quede claro lo voy a escribir aquí
explícitamente b de 0 es igual a y de 0
por el elevado a de igual a 0 por cada
que quedan 0 por lo que es igual a y de
0 'nuestra y 0 es igual a 100 y recuerda
su expresión entre igual a cero nuestra
be es igual a nuestra y 0 bueno ya
estamos progresando pues ya sabemos que
las bacterias como en función del tiempo
van a ser igual a
por el elevado a la corte si supiéramos
cuál es el valor de acá pues ya
tendríamos este primer inciso cómo
podemos encontrar el valor de k bueno
nos están dando otro dato después de una
hora la población se ha incrementado a
420 y esto qué significa
bueno cuando t es igual a 1 b de 1 va a
ser igual a nuestro valor inicial 100
por el elevado a cada por 1 que es igual
a 1 bueno todo esto lo estoy pensando en
voz alta pero vamos a escribirlos si no
no me van a entender nada después de una
hora la población se ha incrementado 420
bacterias
entonces habíamos dicho que ve de 1
después de una hora
es igual a 420 que a su vez es igual a
esta fórmula que escribimos acá
que es igual a 100 x elevado a la k por
t y t es igual a 1 así que queda elevado
a la k 'aquí estamos' paso a pasito de
lo que les comenté hace rato
ahora vamos a despejar
vamos a dividir ambos lados entre 100
nos queda 4.2
nos queda a la cara igual a 4.2
y ahora para despejar acá vamos a sacar
el logaritmo natural en ambos lados de
esta igualdad
y tenemos que igual a logaritmo natural
de 4.2 que va a ser un número medio
extraño después encontraremos ese
cálculo vamos a dejarlo así por el
momento usando las condiciones iniciales
acabamos de encontrar este valor y de
cero y usando este otro dato acabamos de
encontrar nuestra caja y encontramos que
cada es igual a logaritmo natural de 4.2
y esto que nos deja ahora ya conocemos
la ecuación del inciso a conocemos el
valor de cada y el valor del 0 por lo
que nuestra ecuación queda la ecuación
es vedette
bacterias cómo funciona el tiempo es
igual al número inicial de bacterias que
100 x
alak aporte cada acabamos de encontrar
que es logaritmo natural de 4.2 x t así
que tenemos nuestra función completa y
ahora ya podemos pasar a responder
nuestro segundo inciso nuestra parte b
que dice encontrar el número de
bacterias después de 3 horas y esto es
bastante directo ya que tenemos esta
fórmula simplemente reemplazamos el
valor de t por 3 ya que el tiempo es de
3 horas y resolver la ecuación con este
valor b de 3 va a ser igual a 100 por el
elevado a logaritmo natural de 4.2
x té pero te es igual a 3 x 3
y podemos calcular este número lo
podemos resolver de forma analítica y yo
creo que lo vamos a hacer para que quede
más claro
esta es igual a 100 x
elevado a logaritmo natural de 4.2 si se
tienen dos cosas en un exponente que
están multiplicándose sería lo mismo que
escribir esto como si lo tuviéramos todo
a la tercera potencia así que ahora
vamos a calcular que es elevado a
logaritmo natural de 4.2 pues es 4.2
bueno aquí exponente tengo que elevar mi
e para tener como resultado un 4.2 pues
el logaritmo natural
y me quedaría 100 por 4.2 elevado al
cubo y bueno esto sería cercano a
setenta y tantos pero lo vamos a
resolver más adelante al menos ya
tenemos el valor de nuestro inciso b
esta es la respuesta del inciso b bueno
ahora que nos piden el inciso se dice
encontrar la razón de crecimiento
después de tres horas
la razón de crecimiento y esto lo vamos
a hacer en otro color que es lo que nos
están pidiendo aquí en esencia es la
pendiente de esta función después de
tres horas de esta función de acá
después de tres horas otra forma de
verlo es cuál es la derivada de esta
función cuando el tiempo es igual a 3 y
vamos a hacer justamente esto pero antes
permítanme hacer un poco de espacio aquí
creo que podemos borrar esto ya que
tengo la ecuación de este otro lado esto
también lo quitamos incluso pues podemos
quitar todo
aquí tenemos nuestra función
vamos a hacer nuestro inciso c
y encontrar la razón de crecimiento
después de 3 horas
para esto primero tenemos que encontrar
la derivada de esta función
ve prima de té
es igual a qué
cuál es la derivada de esto vamos a usar
la regla de la cadena
sabemos que este 100 es una constante
entonces lo podemos poner aquí aparte
que multiplicar la derivada de esta
parte de aquí así que la derivada es el
logaritmo natural de 4.2
multiplicada por la derivada de elevado
a todo esto la derivada de ea la x es a
la x así que escribimos va a quedar
igual multiplicamos esto por el elevado
el logaritmo natural
de 4.2
por t esta es la derivada para cualquier
tiempo t pero lo que nos piden es la
razón de crecimiento después de tres
horas de prima de 3 es igual a 100
por logaritmo natural de 4.2 todo eso
que multiplica a qué es esto
esto lo hicimos en el inciso b
^ logaritmo natural de cuatro puntos dos
por tres por tres y nos queda 4.2
elevado al cubo
es matemática logarítmica lo que se hizo
aquí tiene la misma lógica que en el
inciso b espero que tenga sentido para
ustedes si no siempre pueden usar su
calculadora para verificarlo de todas
maneras nunca olviden que si tienen
elevado al logro natural de x
es lo mismo que tener x aquí eso
significa a qué exponente tengo que
elevar y para obtener el valor x si
elevó a ese exponente pues obtengo x
esta misma regla es la que estamos
explicando acá va más en detalle tenemos
el logaritmo natural de 4.2 elevado a la
t esto lo simplificamos tomamos este
exponente y lo pusimos en esta otra
parte por lo que esto es 4.2 elevado a
la t
en este caso t es igual a 3 y bueno creo
que dije haber escrito esto en la
ecuación original hace unos cuantos
incisos y podríamos escribir nuestra
ecuación original de bacterias como 100
x aplicando el mismo principio por 4.2
elevado a la potencia de t por lo que
ésta sería una ecuación de bacterias
mucho más simple que esta otra así que
esta sería una respuesta aún mejor que
la primera
para este inciso por lo que la parte b
también sería mucho más fácil de
resolver
y bueno parte ce pues fue bastante
sencillo de encontrar también ya que en
esta forma original el encontrar la
derivada es algo mucho más sencillo de
esta otra manera hubiera sido un poquito
más difícil de derivar pero bueno en
esta forma original fue bastante
sencillo encontrar la primera derivada
podríamos reescribir la derivada como be
prima de t igual a 100
por logaritmo natural 4.2
todo esto por 4.2 a la t
simplemente tomamos esto y lo
sustituimos acá bueno de hecho es esto
lo que tome y que estoy sustituyendo acá
bueno queda un poquito revuelto vamos a
pasar a resolver la última pregunta en
cuánto tiempo a la población alcanzará
las 10 mil células ahora vamos a borrar
a borrar esto que ya resolvimos
para resolver el inciso c cuando la
población llegará a las 10.000 células
ok
describir lo que ya tenemos de una forma
más ordenada de la parte habíamos que
vedete es igual a 100 x
^ logaritmo natural de 4.2 por t
y dijimos que esto es igual a 100 x
4.2 elevado a la t
y la pregunta es en qué momento este
valor va a alcanzar las 10.000 células
así que 10.000 es igual a esto 100 x
100 x y bueno creo que de hecho voy a
usar esta otra versión de la función con
el logaritmo natural
porque al logaritmo
el logaritmo natural 4.2 por t
vamos a dividir a ambos lados entre 100
nos queda 100 que es igual a elevado
al logaritmo natural
de 4.2 porte y ahora podemos tomar el
logaritmo natural en ambos lados de esta
igualdad nos queda
que es igual a vamos a ponerlo en otro
color
el organismo natural de 100
es igual
el logaritmo natural de el elevado a un
exponente nos va a quedar solamente el
exponente ustedes pueden realizar las
reglas en los logaritmos y esto les
confunde un poco pero si tomamos el
logaritmo natural de este lado nos va a
quedar solamente el exponente por lo que
va a ser igual a logaritmo natural de
4.2 por t
y si queremos despejar te tenemos que
dividir todo entre logaritmo natural de
4.2 por lo que nos queda que t es igual
a logaritmo natural de 100 entre el
logaritmo natural de 4.2 así pues para
saber cuántas horas toma llegar a este
valor simplemente ponemos esto en la
calculadora para obtener el valor de t
espero que esto no nos esté confundiendo
y simplemente para aclarar un poco más
esto podemos usar esta otra función para
obtener este valor como lo hubiéramos
hecho bueno tendríamos 100 x 4.2 elevado
este dividir a ambos lados entre 100 nos
quedaría 4.2 elevado a la t igual a 100
y para resolver esto lo que tenemos que
hacer es es tomar el logaritmo en base a
4.2 en ambos lados de la igualdad
así que nos queda que este es igual a
logaritmo en base 4.2
de 100
y se vio esto en los vídeos de las
propiedades de los logaritmos lo cual es
algo bastante útil de saber de manera
general cómo calcular esto bueno tienen
dos tipos de organismos los logaritmos
en base 10 y los logaritmos en base n
como se ha calculado el logaritmo que
está en otra base como en este caso
bueno la respuesta es que pueden tomar
el logaritmo natural de esto y dividirlo
por el logaritmo natural de esto o
también pueden tomar el logaritmo en
base 10 de esto y dividirlo entre el
logaritmo en base 10 de esto de estas
maneras espero no haberlos confundido
más con esto esto fue el crecimiento
exponencial y pueden reemplazar estas
palabras que en lugar de referirse
bacterias pueden referirse a una cuenta
que tienes de inicio 100 dólares y que
va aumentando a una razón proporcional a
su tamaño lo que indica que es un
crecimiento compuesto y en lugar de que
diga después de una hora la población se
ha incrementado a 420 bacterias pueden
decir que se ha incrementado a 420
dólares y en este caso ustedes
encontrarían el interés compuesto sobre
dinero pero es exactamente el mismo
fenómeno más adelante haremos más
ejemplos al respecto porque pueden
llegar a ser un poco confusos nos vemos
pronto